hola
[Música]
la historia de los pueblos
afrodescendientes
y su contribución continuada en nuestros
países ha sido sistemáticamente
invisibilizado
desde los espacios formales de educación
en donde por ejemplo se omite cualquier
referencia al continente africano
excepto cuando se habla de egipto y se
habla de egipto como si no se tratara de
un país en el continente africano se
hacen limitadísima de referencias
autores autoras investigadores
investigadoras o simplemente son casi
inexistentes
autores o autoras de la diáspora
africana
al mismo tiempo hay una gran ausencia de
imágenes publicitarias en donde se
observan personas afrodescendientes en
muy poca proporción en que se colocan
personas de otros grupos de hecho es
notable la preferencia a colocar
personas con pieles y cabellos más
claros que realmente no representan el
promedio de la población costarricense
en términos artísticos asimismo se
tiende a estereotipar folklore izar y
singularizar en una sola región
las características de los pueblos
afrodescendientes
sin real reconocimiento a los aportes de
tan importante comunidad todos los
elementos apuntados por supuesto
contribuyen a la perpetuación del
racismo y van en definitiva en
detrimento del respeto y la autoestima
de los pueblos afrodescendientes
es la educación formal las políticas de
acción afirmativa y el reconocimiento lo
que eventualmente va a contribuir para
acabar con el racismo el arte y la
poesía pueden contribuir a los procesos
educativos con el potencial de modificar
comportamientos y transformar el futuro
de los pueblos para la igualdad de
oportunidades de todas las personas al
mismo tiempo la poesía es una forma
maravillosa de sanar el alma y
contribuir a la historia
como puede está pero descendiente y
comprometida con mis comunidades creo
que la poesía es capaz de transformar a
través de la lectura de algunos poemas
vamos a encontrarnos con la historia
este encuentro va a permitir conversar
con ella
increparla por su participación limitada
en la historia de los pueblos
afrodescendientes
vamos a leer algunos poemas que nos van
a permitir
entonces hablar con la historia
porque siempre tuvimos su historia
a pesar de que nos fue negada y ocultada
siempre tuvimos historia estaba desde
antes desde mucho tiempo atrás
estaba antes de fogatas y alabanzas
tú ya escribía desde antes a mí esa
historia de ustedes me encontró ya de
entrada en las palabras mi mano ya venía
untada de poesía y de canciones que
empezaron a escribirse mucho antes de
cuerdas vocales
antes de los cuerpos que caminan
erguidos antes de fogatas y alabanzas
escribíamos desde antes porque aún antes
de la historia hubo palabras que se
preguntaron y se perpetuaron y se
grabaron en célebres en árboles y en
cuerpos y en los silencios más ingratos
de la historia que ustedes contaron esas
palabras de ustedes ya no se encontraron
inmersos en danzas y en historias no se
encontraron ya inscritos en el tiempo
nuestras palabras estaban ya escritas en
formas y en fosas en estructuras
magníficas en tambores que ya avanzaban
y acompañaban la construcción de
monumentos inventaban caminos que
inventaban historia
ya para cuando ustedes aparecen
agolpados en las memorias nuestras
palabras
describían tiempos desde mucho antes de
aquí
esas memorias que ustedes apenas
alcanzan a nombrar apenas alcanzan para
contar una mínima parte de la historia
una parte insignificante
de la verdad
yo escribía antes de aquí la historia de
ustedes ya no se encontraba de entrados
en las palabras nuestras manos venían ya
agitadas y resueltas de tanto escrito en
piedras y en fogatas en caminos y en
libros de hojas sueltas como árboles y
selvas
construimos palabras que desde entonces
mucho más allá de ustedes se
transformaron en pueblos y grandes
civilizaciones las palabras de ustedes
apenas se alcanzan para escribir una
parte mínima de la experiencia ancestral
y tan humana de los míos
mi voz la de mis pueblos
alcanza más allá del principio porque
son largas historias repetidas como al
unísono desde cuando levantábamos la voz
para tocar astros y cielos de otras
partes y mis escritos esos que ustedes
no se cansan de negar
aún sin tanta palabra innecesaria sin
tanta imagen incoherente sin tanta
arrogancia que lastima aun sin tanta
sangre plasmada en su heroísmo
ya se escribía desde entonces
nuestros escritos
nuestras palabras
nuestro testimonio
viene desde mucho más allá de mí y con
la precisión que sólo otorga la verdad
y es que nuestra historia no nos llegó
en capítulos ni de menor a mayor como
suele suceder no nos llegó desde el
principio desde la cuna no nos llegó
desde los primeros días de escuela no
nos apareció en libros o en las
sorpresas de los cereales o esas cosas
se nos portó cruel y egoísta se nos
mantuvo oculta como una ladrona como
quien se resiste a dar luz y compartir
ella nos llegó en lenguajes desconocidos
nos llegó fragmentada
interpretada por los enemigos y nos
llegó en sus rostros y en sus verdades
se nos entregó sucia vacía hecha pedazos
nos llegó
acribillada
descalza la recogimos
humillada fue necesario que saliéramos
como valientes guerreras a recuperarla
limpiarle las lágrimas las manos
vestirla de nuevo llenarla de orgullo y
cuando estuvo lista la sacamos al sol y
nuestra historia entonces luce hermosa
resplandeciente fuerte y camina desde
entonces con el pecho erguido y la
mirada
esa negativa de mostrarse de la historia
de pronto una descubre que la tiene que
siempre la tuvo teníamos historia y nos
podríamos sentir orgullosos de nuestra
propia historia
una descubre que nos fue negada
ocultada
y decide que va a enfrentar a la
historia
hoy estoy dispuesta a escuchar
pero no quiero excusas vacías o verdades
a medias voy a escuchar pero quiero la
verdad
de lo contrario corremos el riesgo de
pecar de nuevo de mentir de nuevo de
llorar dos veces de morir
inexorablemente
hoy estoy dispuesta a escuchar una
explicación sensata por todos los
muertos las humillaciones por todas las
madres huérfanas de hijos por todas las
hijas huérfanas de madres
hoy estoy dispuesta a escuchar
pero no quiero escuchar otras verdades
que no sean las verdaderas
que no sean las más humanas pero estoy
dispuesta escuchar el nombre de los
hechos por su nombre el color de mis
hijos por su nombre el sueño de mi
abuela a todas voces
voy a sentarme despojarme del rencor del
odio de la vergüenza del orgullo voy a
escuchar a ver que tienen ustedes que
decir
es que había que enfrentarla había que
pedirle cuentas y entonces un día yo me
lo encontré y le enfrente
después de todo es necesario
desenmascarar la historia y hacerla
escupir con sangre la verdad
era necesario sentar la frente a los
nuestros y hacerla hablar y entonces
hablo
me contó entre gritos sobre los primeros
las primeras voces en poblar la tierra
me contó llorando del principio humano
me dijo despacio que se arrepentía que
la perdonara mos y que la humanidad
con certeza inició en áfrica era
necesario desenmascarar la eran muchos
años de estar esperando era mucho tiempo
detrás de los otros le amarre los brazos
la mira a los ojos la apatía en el
vientre y escupió llorando toda la
verdad me habló del principio empezó a
balbuceando palabras casi inentendibles
acerca de inventos y civilizaciones
lejanas de mujeres negras armando su
historia de valientes hombres reinando
por siglos de inventos de sueños de
escritos de mapas de revoluciones y
devoluciones de sueños de muertes de
siembras cosechas
estaba llorando
como quien de pronto
después de los siglos después de la vida
descubre violentamente que se equivocó
se equivocó con muerte y el error le
costó millones y millones de almas era
necesario desenmascarar la y arranque a
pedazos trozos del cabello le rompía el
vestido le mordí la cara le arranque los
dientes y escupió llorando toda la
verdad me habló del pasado de un
crucificado llamado jesús me dijo entre
súplicas que buscar en áfrica toda la
verdad que me remitiera a libros
enterrados a hombres temerosos de ser
descubiertos y a falsos testigos que
juraron estar sin estar
ella estaba llorando
lloraba con sangre toda la verdad
intenté golpearla de nuevo en la boca y
en un largo grito me pidió perdón me
dijo entre voces que se arrepentía que
después de todo no era solamente su
error en ese momento yo le di la espalda
no quería verla nunca más
yo estaba llorando
ya no valía la pena echar culpas o
escupir rostros a mi espalda yo la sentí
muriendo
yo estaba llorando es que no se puede
vivir sin historia no se pueden criar
hijos sin historia
entonces sentí pena por ella
se lo merecía era necesario
desenmascarar la y hacerla escupir con
sangre la verdad
la escuela ha sido siempre para niños y
niñas afrodescendientes un espacio de
estrés
a mí no se sienten validados al mismo
tiempo que sufren muchas veces el
rechazo de compañeros y compañeras que
por supuesto se ve reforzado por una
ausencia de contenidos educativos que
promuevan el respeto y la igualdad
la escuela que yo quiero es una escuela
distinta
los niños vinieron uno por uno y
entonces con los días la casa se empezó
a llenar de animales de flores y sonidos
primero vino un gato que tenía los ojos
grandes y una estrella en la cola luego
vinieron los elefantes y se acomodaron
en el comedor y se empeñaron en contarme
historias de ancestros y de mapas de
sueños y tesoros con el tiempo llegaron
las serpientes y se acomodaron en el
patio justo detrás de las veraneras que
habían llegado sólo dos días antes
con ellas vino un gorila una jirafa y
tres tortugas gigantes el patio de
pronto estaba lleno de enormes árboles
de cascadas y desiertos fue entonces
cuando llegaron las complicaciones
alguien noto entonces que yo tenía un
par de estrellas en los ojos y que
caminaba extraño como danzando dicen que
ya no era la misma fue por ese mismo
tiempo que empecé a observar que los
niños guardaban señales y miradas y
escondían cosas en los armarios entonces
los descubrí encontré 8 ancianas 22
curanderos y 17 contadores de historias
y 12 mujeres cantando en un rincón de la
casa para entonces ya era tarde les
habían enseñado a vivir con el pecho
abierto y la frente erguida podían
deletrear el universo con los ojos
cerrados con una certeza de pasado que
yo no recordaba haber tenido fue por ese
mismo tiempo cuando empecé a temer y me
dije si no sería que estaba teniendo
alucinaciones decidí que era tiempo de
volver fue un viaje largo y cansado sin
embargo durante todo el tiempo los niños
no dejaron de reír de cantar gritaban
oraciones y alababan a los árboles y las
estrellas e iban con frecuencia al baño
fue hasta que llegamos a la casa que su
mirada cierta volvió a delatarlos los
descubrí se habían robado 12 curanderos
tres parteras y 32 contadores de
historias
fue necesario que construyéramos una
casa más grande ahora sabemos todos los
niños que cuentan aproximadamente 16 los
cuentos las leyendas los sueños los
animales las verdades del orgullo en fin
ya estamos completos los niños ya no van
a la escuela y las maestras a menudo nos
acompañan a la hora de las historias
muchas gracias